hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within now
you may notice that it actually looks a
little better because it was an update
of the game and not only did they
disable or activate an option to disable
the letterboxing on this so that it
actually is in sixteen by nine doesn't
just look like it right but what who's
alright did you shoot me in the head
Jojo I've had it up to here with you but
if you're gonna be you don't need to
worry about me yeah too tough way too
manly and tough to be but oh well this
looks fun so anyway they also allowed it
to go to 60 frames per second
okay well this place got a little
horrifying
why don't you quiet down there Skippy
what's with the giant hammer there gonna
be a reason that something's gonna be
using a giant hammer on me or anything
around me I gotta admit playing games
and 60 frames per second is so much
better than playing it in 30 frames per
second which is what it was locked at
before for the sake of consoles but my
computer is pretty beefy it's been
taking some roids what the hell is going
on here okay so certain things get
letterbox but for the most part I don't
have to do an actual holes happening
oh that's bad what do I need to do oh
god they're all rising this one's a
solves a small bag oh I think I know
what's in the small bag okay well a cha
I just felt like doing that forgot I
forgot the buttons that just came out
for playing alien isolation so I'm a
little bit kerfuffled about what exactly
I need to do where are you Joe Joe Joe
Joe don't touch a damn thing Joe Joe
what are you doing Joe Joe what do you
make of this writing doesn't mean
anything to me should it yeah hold on a
second I jotted something down earlier
aren't you just so smart yeah Joe Joe
has all the answers
tell me Oh Joe Joe all that candles
burning your butt off the sacrifices
need to be lowered onto the proper
altars and the safe way to him will be
open good oh good so I need to sacrifice
all these douchebags in a proper order
such that it does not hurt me oh that
guy looks so sad so there's a big old
one on that one am I looking for a
symbol on the body that's definitely not
on the thing okay so I got to match up
the symbols somehow so there's got to be
some outside clue to all this here we go
oh so smooth oh god yes oh thank you I
need more of those as I spasmed and used
all of it
oh so strong okay some actual gear boxes
to be able to make stuff some agony
bolts from agony crossbow my friend oh
there's something on you
oh just gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
yeah you clinging on to that I'll show
you a thing or two yep
ah come on have five there we go give me
give me give me yes the delicious key
that I don't know if it really helps me
or not okay so let's solve this up so
that's an M on there
it's kind of an M like thing oh maybe
that's the three wait a minute okay
oh those are numbers on there I thought
those are symbols 2 3 5 7 9 the 3 5 and
the 9 all have strikes through them I'm
guessing that's a three of sorts it's a
5 over there 7 here so 7 is the only one
that's not crossed out but it's also the
small bag am I supposed to make of that
okay well I knew let's go seven first
okay any day you want it go up there we
go
seven okay so this is safe Jojo you want
to go first okay here we go
whoa
maybe we should Jojo your warnings are
not very intense okay so how about this
one what is this one gonna do
okay okay okay so I got it okay okay
okay so these are supposed to be lowered
on the platforms and the platform's
themselves go down sorry to save me a
while I'm gonna get it done
Oh grody talaq that did a thing all guy
ruin every that's supposed to be the
other ones are supposed to be down
because they have to strike through but
this one with this little itty-bitty
package is supposed to be Oh got it
I'm smart maybe her chuckles okay bye
okay yeah me too
all right come on Jojo follow along like
a good little puppy
yeah
I don't want to go down there reader
okay oh yeah Jojo just feel free to step
right in this ain't weird at all
oh please tell me we're not going down
good we would easily drown if we would
have gone down good for us I guess what
do you got for me game come along Jojo I
can't whistle on command okay
Oh what is all this central nervous
system spine empty and empty I guess
it's for me and Jojo bullets can't open
that up
that's so much smoother at 60 frames per
second I like it's so much better
together cemetary lab no number one it
it had to have been God's will that
these two twin orphans survived they
were baptized and given medicine nuran
and his brothers n quickly recovered but
just as it did quickly did their
aberration progress of course they are
twins but for some reason they're gross
patterns exhibit identical values 12
hours after serum administered body
temperature elevated pain and lower
extremities evident okay whoa oh
they grew fast oh my goodness whoa
speaking to imaginary person Oh 48 hours
they gained a lot of weight were those
that switched roles that I killed I'm
sorry I beat up your dude oh no one ends
in grody that was them oh okay gotcha
well good thing they were baptized first
at least that happened okay oh hi didn't
notice you there
so uh whoa what are you what are all of
you what are any of you come along Jojo
come on well that's an interesting sound
that sounded almost like exactly stock
footage of us of a lion or tiger what is
that what is that Cemetery alive no
number two every month offerings are
brought above ground to the stone
sarcophaguses of the owner calls the
altar
two bodies four bodies three body five
body for body seven body six bodies the
church guard dog has begun to change
just like the twins the aberration is
progressing it devoured six bodies today
and already it house for more it has
begun to stress its bars and chains in
its fervor
I don't dare take my eyes away from that
animal it may think I am another
offering goody goody gumdrops
is this a guard dog oh he's adorable
and by adorable I mean absolutely
horrifying
good golly look at you I guess I'm gonna
get a closer look at you soon enough I'm
gonna say I'm gonna get in real close
look at you
come along Jojo this is a bad place to
be you don't wanna mess with that doggie
all right what do we got a bear way out
no
okay I thought Jojo might have to stand
on that I would have been able to leave
that's a bad sound can you get it open
that's the sound of a doggy Jojo you
might want to work quick cuz I don't
think we have a lot of time okay Jojo
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna just stand around and do
nothing
well we will we go where'd you go oh
you're in the bushes what am I supposed
to Oh
why Jojo this is some kind of ridiculous
aning okay well then glad I get a chance
how many bullets anyway I couldn't shut
you if I wanted to and I do want to miss
man
okay well this is gonna suck so I need
to go god oh god oh god oh god I'm hurt
Joe Joe I'm done I'm gonna be dead I'm
gonna be dead I'm dead
suck on that have another whoa I'm super
dead okay so obviously is some kind of
dodge mechanic but I don't know if I
have a dodge roll or anything anytime
you want to help don't oh are you doing
so good god Joe Joe if you could just
get up for like a second okay no no no
no don't don't don't don't don't I swear
to god don't hey doggie come on right
where I'm running you sack of crap come
on come on I wanna fight you I want to
do it do it come on hit me
who's me I'm here
Hey
okay what about that you done you're
done you're done you're done son
you're done get done that's right Oh
Jojo you look so good without your
glasses so glad you could help me out
my man need there's a lot of moaning
going on mmm oh I could have squeezed
through that gap at any time okay
oh it's back up isn't it what is it
I dropped my glasses back there yeah
[Music]
well he's gonna be very useful
oh god whatever six I'm so screwed
what are we doing exactly do I need to
go back there are you kidding me
I need to go back in oh you son of a
[ __ ]
oh you son of a [ __ ] so so how about
being a nice that's boochi boochi
Sebastian I'll draw it away so you can
search I already know where it is I'm
two feet away from it thanks for drawing
it away I got it okay I gotta go okay
bye let's thanks for drawing it right to
me Jojo you know what Jojo I shouldn't
have done that I shouldn't but I'm nice
sorry it's not just about being unable
to see it's about feeling normal
it's alright let's focus on finding
Kidman okay let's do that that sounds
like a good idea I got the glasses you
Welcome Party
you're welcome friend now you'll be able
to soar board me with sniper flyers
Joseph all that for a pair of glasses
but I didn't really do much I just went
back in didn't really take a lot of
effort didn't even come after me I
didn't even have to fire mmm
green D and I don't know why I didn't
get a reward for shooting down that big
a hole but oh well I guess we're back at
the church now hopefully there'd be
something yeah come along Jojo we got a
lot of game to play here getting into
the nitty-gritty you're wise
oh is it clear well it's not time to end
the episode yet so I guess I'll just do
one more
please this one overwrite the save yes
yes come on let's get into it next
chapter let's do this do it do it okay
that looks nice
oh there's the hooded lady again and I
feel so safe in here
hey goodies bullets items yes please
whatever that is since matches isn't
damn it I got plenty of matches that
sounded close oh it's Kidman yes map
fragment I don't know what these do but
I got another one yeah you're being
really creepy hello hello down there
okay well I won't call down I guess
because that would just be comforting
those shotgun shells over here that's a
place for him as a church you're just
still with me Oh Sebastian you ever had
the urge to just jump
when you're on a high place no or the
subway rolls by
imagine if you had that urge for him and
hit straight then two minutes you fought
it off three times now Joseph you're
learning to stop it you're not listening
I'm not worried about stopping it Seth
I'm worried about not wanting to stop it
some part of me wants to turn
and I can't reason it away it's deeper
than that
it's like instinct
it's getting stronger
[Music]
hold on
I
oh boy well this ain't good don't bless
em Jojo grow up this shit's getting real
who maybe they lifted off the prison so
that I can go down there now
that's not normal it's really cool Jojo
why aren't you being affected because
he's grounded awesome super cool I don't
know what the hell just happened but I
love mind-bending games oh so cool I
don't even know what's happening right
now but I love it
hello chapter 7 the keeper well does
that mean that I'm a keeper or that
there's a keeper keeping me in this
place where did I go
and my beneath the church is Jojo sell
up above Leslie that's creepy
I better start searching for my partners
yeah that would be a good idea there
anything on these offering tables that I
would need I don't want to start
smashing up stuff willy-nilly but here
we go there we go
anything else I know there's stuff in
there but I just want to make sure
there's nothing you like over here I
like that green goo be gobby right there
I'll take that I hate those bombs yeah
I'll take the bullets okay can you son
of a [ __ ]
okay I can pick him up while crouching
why didn't I do that in the first place
that would have made my life a whole lot
easier
screw your ancient artifacts I'm gonna
break it to get green brain goop where
yet Leslie Leslie I heard him whoa what
are you okay then I swear I just heard
him
looky nothing Oh up here okay
Leslie Kidman I'm on the way I fell
through the floor quite literally and
everything when anti-gravity okay
did not did not know that this was about
to start all right so I'm gonna be
stealthy all right am i far I am I are
you gonna do you look like you could use
a bolt right through the brain is this I
don't know if this crossbow is actually
quiet wanting to snake for a bit before
I get too close to him well hello wait
whoa whoa how do you what no no way
you're done you're also done boom trick
yeah that other guy though he's gonna
get up yeah I knew it
bad gone so all these guys are dead for
good I was actually pretty easy
I handled that quite well and though I
did waste some bolts that's okay bolts
are easy to come by I thought I could
pick one back up after I shot it
all right then didn't know no I needed
to do that okay I'm just kicking bodies
willy-nilly that looks useful that was
not the used button why did I hop in all
right then
Sebastian you weirdo you just do
whatever you're doing sniper rifle ammo
nothing any vampires in the sarcophagi
no I'll just be on my way I seriously
don't know why that guy came after me
it's not like I made a noise I was all
that visible I was in the darkness bah
bah mr. rat okay looks loose so punch it
well there's your knife come on kid Oh
old Luther graph this lithograph was
pried from a stone door where it seems
to have been used as a key how do you
know oh let me just collect all the
items over here first
sorry something happened in there Brody
well the lights came back on so I guess
that's good is that supposed to spook me
is that all of the spoof you got game
oh there's that box again
oh wait disarmed
what is that how do i disarm that Oh
grody I did not know that was the thing
that I could disarm or else I would have
tried it on the other one that I saw
before bingo again that is not the used
bucket catacomb note helped the metallic
pounding he's coming I run but he
follows help god help help help help
help help help help help well I was
helpful for me told me a lot about your
state of mind anything over here no
carrying on any other goobers that I
should shoot in the face seems to be my
main prerogative in this game oh it's
down here Kidman was Lee it's me
Sebastian well then good thing that guy
locked himself away in a box so uh
alright then I'm very strong strong
enough to break a solid iron lock with
my bare hands
ha not sorry enough to kill anybody that
looks important yep Lily's birth
announcement we welcome with love Lily
Lynn Castellanos born July 18 2006 956
a.m. seven pounds three ounces 14 inches
proud parents Sebastian and Mira
Castellanos that's good
yeah into the void we go
catacombs found beneath the parish
that's good I do not know that I was
supposed to be reading this category and
many parish pastor says nothing to lose
sleep over who took care of this place
workmen repairing collapse floor
discover man-made passages beneath Cedar
Hill Church claim they saw mummies
parish denies access to historians
claiming sacrilege okay you don't know
me don't don't act like you do know me
so I'm just gonna go back here and open
a thing sounds different something's
definitely different and all sudden I
started getting more pieces of the map
right away I don't know if that's
because I'm looking closer something it
right what do you got for me baby
sniper ammunition I think that's the one
thing that I have plenty of what you got
for me another key goodie Oh two keys
perfect excellent I picked the winner
there that gonna be in a $5 five now
what you got for me baby Martin Morris
hyperbole it's good I get it you're
trying to tell me to shoot things with a
sniper rifle I I get it all right
so if that's how it's gonna be then I'm
gonna upgrade I guess my sniper rifle
cache cuz I mean the sniper is a verb
powerful gun if I can land the head
shots when I need to and it's gonna be
exactly what the doctor ordered a lot of
pain in someone else's face
over there yes why can't these doors
stay open Chris Taylor construction
foreman disappeared while overseeing
repairs of a fallen church floor repairs
were nearly completed so it is unlikely
he fell okay
why are all the clues inside this place
related to the church is that the secret
behind all this is that what I'm
supposed to know about I have no idea
okay so anyway a lot of people said that
I need to upgrade my life more than I do
a lot of things and I did so I'm gonna
do it again and then I'm gonna upgrade
melee damage I wanna but what in the
hell am I gonna use melee only all the
time I don't know Oh more sprint god
damn it I almost feel real bad ten
seconds Plus that would be amazing I
don't think it's ever gonna happen but
oh wow good thing that solid injection
of goop into my brain oh that's much
better gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
when I get back to the real word I
better discover that this guy can run
for miles and miles without tiring
okay bye babe what I'll see you in the
next episode thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you
[Music]
Oh